[Music]
you loved hook you think pan looks kind
of cool and you laughed your butt off at
NBC's live version tuna pan has found a
mother now revisit the animated classic
that will make you say this is way
creepier than I remembered Peter Pan
prepare for a film about an immortal
trickster who spies on you through your
bedroom window sprinkles you a dust that
makes you feel like you're flying
then kidnaps you to a war to an island
where full-grown adults force orphans to
join their ranks or die it's like a
magical Sudan leave your everyday
worries behind as you travel to
Neverland and trade them in for more
serious worries like being burned alive
[Music]
drowned by mermaids or having your
throat slit by pirates and join the Lost
Boys an all-male group of motherless
furries who live underneath a tree that
is clearly still used for hanging people
this is a kids story right what are
you're about to time I cut off Hook's
hand to the crocodiles
see this magical realm through the eyes
of the darling children three darling
children who turned that okay even
though they were raised by a dog get
left home alone and live with this
rageaholic who looks nothing like them
but they sure looked a lot like Peter
Pan and their mom definitely believes in
it mrs. darling believed the Peter Pan
was the spirit of youth just saying
opposing Peter Pan's fairy dictatorship
is Captain James Hook a man who's given
up pirating to focus all his energy on
murdering a twee and when he fails takes
out his infinite rage on his life
partner Smee
oh really just anyone
whoa did he just kill that guy but it's
not all darkness violence and Oedipus
complex is you can be our mother I think
there's plenty of sexism to go around to
get on with a girl jealous female can be
tricked into anything girls talk too
much but who cares about sexism because
Disney makes up word by including lots
of roles for Native Americans oh well I
don't even remember that part wow that
is really bad okay enough enough stop
those Redskins know these hilum just
switch to another Disney movie well I'm
glad they don't be no trouble not that
one no don't show that when show a
different woman oh that was so much
worse these are all so much worse than I
remember go to starring go to starring
starring Teen Mom
link to worker Belle Buster Bluth the
Washington DC football team
sneezy sir and some little mermaids
Disney's Michael Jackson so his name was
hooked before Peter cut off his hand and
I thought scar was a convenient villain
aim be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers there once was a man from a
foreign land
his name was Peter Pan I'm like hey
what's up hello a hero is nothing but a
sandwich grab that gem the flesh he's
super strong and super naked you thought
Jojo was your first but it was me do